あの
透明な飲み物
おすきませんこんにちははじめしゃちょーでそれは本当に疑問を抱いている今の飲料水
業界に本当に最近 a 透明な飲み物が
を頭切れビッグ立安倉伊藤面談のいうものがありますよ
何と名なコーラと名なヨーグルトの飲み物多めなヨーグルトと望むもののブドヴァ染め
なイチゴドリン高齢やカルピス大根
そげん3透明なねえねええっ
まあトータルる本当にびっくりするぐらい透明の伸びをのブームがいま来てまして
まあで答弁になっちゃうで同時たことだった僕は疑問を持っております何でなんですか
ねやっぱと女のほうがなんかの中がないから痩せる気がするんですから行ったに僕が今
売ってる女入ったこれ透明じゃない視聴
って思ったの色の一覧でございます上田コーラってもすごいです4色あってこその航路
みたいなところでほんとびっくりしました
いただけます
なんか
膣よくわかんないしても多分コーラの味なんだと思いますよグリーナ
ん
所よくわかんないですレヴェリーをグリーナ
oo
ちょっとよくわかんないですいろはす15もう何だろうこれどうなってんだろう
終わり予想以上に15
という効果音聡明なカルピスとかまずめっちゃそれやばいぜ
goo
スキゾ店な中古がねそれさあもうすごいの創建日粋なんだをじゃないんだ
います
ん
大爽健美茶を極力薄めた患者から大枝レモンティー
ああ
普通のレポーティング地よくわかんない透明なピーチティー
美味しい色が登野城文盲結構小型平瀬ます
ウィルキンソンタンサンにをレンジャーズが出ていたとはこれも透明部分の性能なのか
あは地聞いてねー
今日も正すに結構畦聞いてんねー
10ですよ俺にそれジュースなんだろうな結局
さーんなまとめなんで私を付けることは全部とっても美味しいです小太刀またあること
を言って言ってしまうダメだぜ飲み音の会社は透明な飲料水用次が釣れと作ってしまう
のだろうかその理由はただ一つ当面な飲み物のおいその限界にみんな色出るのです
知らないけどってことはですよ君たちみんな透明なのに畔を求めてるんだったら
協力した方がいいんじゃない私はそう思ってしまいましたつまり誰だ一言でいうとぜ
ます
みてください恋瀬答弁や曲してキャップ2個せればクリーム抹茶ねぇ全体ものかばっか
聞い紫緑青緑黒兄弟黄緑白オレンジ全体ものでつまり今ちゃすごい済ませてくるのに心
の底ですねこれ情熱的な何かを抱えているんですよそれが透明だからわかる
ないだけでキャップみてくださいおい下がってますね女こそ奴ら力を合わせたらどう
なるのかんってみたいと思いますそれはかなり極論を言わせていただきますと手に
かなったところだと思います4名名乗るものの限界と声とモダンするためには全ての味
のある飲み物の力を合体させなければいけないそうだろう
なんかいっていうねおそらく2年後には世の中のすべての飲み物の色がなくなります
そして5年後人間はヒロを失い10年がこの世は全て欧米になってしまうでしょ
実況二世として俺は未来を変えるしかないとしておればいいんだ
やりますビッグ投影宝動画的には何にも面白くないんだろうねぇ
でキター
見せたモダン骨は多めだった本当キャップが年じゃあもんなんだよなちょっとまずでき
ます
[音楽]
待って空いてはわかってるんだけどなんか潜在レベルで渡ってんだけどこワイヤー
果たして現在と乗り物テクノロジーの頂点に君臨する透明だ飲み物彼らの味が交わった
ときどのような味になるのでしょうか
飲んでみますっびっくり背負って婚活した
入ってくれなんか風呂場の匂いがしましたいいボディーソープを使った後のお風呂場の
new 気がします今日バスロマンいただきます
[音楽]
1枚貼ってっ
だんだんたなんだこれ
わっ
メントスのあるんだ
[音楽]
me
car
me あった
メントスの破片を水に溶かした味がしますお前がどこに向かってんだよ